there is a large argument out there that  we had bush because of you did you cost  Al Gore the election no and Al Gore  agrees ok thinks he thinks he blew it in  Tennessee is home estate everything else  being equal he'd have been in the White  House if he got Tennessee and he thinks  it was stolen in a number of ways in  Florida so but here's where a  libertarian really supports everybody  has an equal right to run for election  right if everybody has an equal right  then we're either all spoilers of one  another trying to get votes from one  another or none of us as spoilers  we're not second-class citizens because  we're a Green Party candidate or  Libertarian Party candidate I have no  trouble with libertarians on that right